okay so for today's voicemail this is
really great the Knoxville
bumper-sticker guy has come out of the
woodwork yesterday I told you that I got
an email or rather there was a reddit
post about how yet again someone in the
Knoxville Tennessee area has been
spotted driving around with the david
pakman show bumper sticker on their car
and I mentioned I remember the Knoxville
guy getting in touch before he actually
spoke to another David Pakman show
viewer at one point and indeed he got in
touch he was parked in a garage recently
which is where his car was supposedly
spotted so anyway we've made contact
here is the bumper sticker guy calling
it hey David this is Jeremy from not so
I'm the bumper sticker guy yeah I called
in those previous two times the guy who
drove up honking his horn and he rolled
down the window and said hey David we've
met he called in and then we kind of
connected over the show another time I
was at Trader Joe's and someone came out
and was looking at my bumper sticker
yeah and I also have one of a piano
keyboard I thought he was looking at
that one but no it was he was like err
like a David Pakman show sticker cool
dude and yeah I was in a parking garage
the other day so that might have been me
again but hope not I hope there's
another guy was another david pakman
show sticker out there and i think it
was you know knoxville actually is it's
pretty conservative at downtown has a
lot of a lot of really cool people
anyway love the show keep it up man
alright well I'm glad we made contact
it is Jeremy in Knoxville that people
are seeing and tomorrow we'll be giving
out his license-plate number no I'm just
kidding bumper sticker sales are surging
though as a result of this as well as
the use of our bumper stickers to cover
Infowars bumper stickers I should have
around five new sort of case studies of
the covering of Infowars bumper stickers
with david pakman show bumper stickers
in the next couple of weeks yeah I love
it
Alex Jones is getting cooked the others
are connecting maybe there should be
like a David Pakman show dating service
then we like you know set it up via
bumper stickers sort of like the Trump
did you hear about the Trump dating site
where it's only for straight people
oh no yeah that that came out like a
couple weeks ago it's weird
uh yeah david pakman show dating maybe
maybe I'm gonna look into that and we'll
talk to uh we'll make a few phone calls
about it we've got a great bonus show
coming up for you today this is such a
funny story Apple has confirmed that
their iCloud storage is actually on
Google's cloud storage like they're
basically subcontracting their own
iCloud storage out to Google which is is
very very funny also California has
scrapped safety driver rules for
self-driving cars meaning that they no
longer will be indefinitely required to
have a safety driver in the vehicle
meaning that despite what Troy York will
call in and say we continue to move in
the direction of self-driving cars and
more stories on today's bonus show sign
up at david pakman.com slash membership
to get instant access we've got a couple
half-price memberships left you can
email me if you want one of them you can
also make a pledge of as little as five
bucks a month to get bonus show access
at patreon.com slash david pakman show